what is the difference between
correlation and causality a correlation
tells us that there is a relationship
between two variables example there is a
positive correlation between ice cream
sales and the number of sunburns however
in existing correlation cannot tell us
which variable influences which or
whether a third variable is responsible
for the correlation in our example both
variables are influenced by a common
cause namely sunny weather on sunny days
people buy more ice cream and spend more
time Outdoors this can lead to an
increased risk of sunburns causality
means that there is a clear cause effect
relationship between two variables
causality exists when you can say with
certainty which variable influences
which